hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and among the topics that i think
doesn't get
enough intellectual respect in the ways
that we talk about the world
is food food is enormously important
right i mean we eat food
every day most of us we think about it a
tremendous amount of our economy is
devoted to growing food
transporting it cooking it deciding how
to eat it
and food plays in in an intimate way to
the history
of the world different countries or
different nation states are trying to
get resources which include growing food
their technological development of a
society can be driven by
ways to make food better or more
interesting or whatever
today's guest rachel louden is a
historian of scientist who became
a historian of food because she realized
that not only is the science of food
very interesting but the
cultural and political and even
religious
history of food is fascinating so she
wrote a wonderful book it's a couple
years old now but maybe you don't know
about it it's called
cuisine and empire the idea being that
different political groups in the
history of the world
have been associated with different
kinds of cuisines and we can trace how
these cuisines change over time by
who invades who who sends their
missionaries to convert who else
and it's important it matters again we
eat the food every day so
thinking about when we eat a certain
meal oh i'm using
rice or i'm using wheat based pasta
or soy beans because of some cultural
history i hadn't even thought of before
so this is a food based podcast but
we're not giving any recipes or anything
like that
we're talking about food as an element
in the greater history of humanity
here on earth uh the religious aspects
are kind of interesting to me the
the war aspects the political and
economic aspects food is everywhere it's
not just in our everyday lives it's sort
of a
something we gotta do it plays an
important role so
hope you've already eaten cause you
might get hungry while we're talking
about this stuff let's go
[Music]
rachel loud and welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm delighted to be here
i have to say here's my opening question
for you when i was reading your book
cuisine and empire i found that it was
much better if i read the book
after having eaten because you're
talking about all these wonderful
food stuffs and it would always get me
hungry if i hadn't eaten yet like is
this an occupational hazard
for those who study the history of
cuisines like you better start eating
before you actually do your work
it's funny you ask that because i have
spent the last 20 years
fighting the view that if you talk about
the history of food
you're talking about something that is
kind of sweet
and feminine and full of feasts
and when i talked to publishers about my
book they all said oh yes
glorious renaissance pictures of feasts
because this is going to be so lovely
and yes of course there's all that and
there is the occupational hazard of
thinking about
food but um
food is part of human life
and it's got its downsides as well as
its upsides
and there's anguish as well as joy
mixed up in food so um
it's it yes
and and politics and uh war
and religion and all these wonderful
things that's what's great about the
book
well how about to get us into it you
know i i couldn't think of a better
choice than you made in the book talking
about your experience in hawaii
which is a little bit of a melting pot
patchwork quilt of
different cuisines coming in at
different times uh do you want to
tell the audience a little bit about uh
how you think about all those different
grains and root vegetables that you
discover when you live in hawaii
yes i mean hawaii was a strange
experience when i first got there
because everybody says it's
just like california you know 2005 miles
off the coast of california and it's not
uh not at all because in california
you are still in a uh
culture that is dominantly western
and in hawaii that is not true
um the uh islands
uh population is made up of three groups
the pacific islanders who got their
um most of them uh
or seven or eight hundred years ago but
have continued to come
from the south pacific uh the
anglos from one to a better word
americans
um british who have been there for a
couple of hundred years
and the asians who are a
very mixed bunch there are chinese hakka
and han okinawans and japanese koreans
filipinos and many others most of whom
came as plantation workers
now what's interesting is that in
when hawaii became a state the
plantation workers voted as a block
and they took over the state government
and so now you have um
a culture where uh
what are still minorities on the
mainland
are not minorities in hawaii and this
uh from the food point of view i learned
two
really important things in hawaii one
was that you've got these teeny weeny
little islands out there
miles from anywhere and
everything that people eat has been
brought in they were a
desert right you could not have survived
in hawaii
so the hawaiians brought everything they
needed their cooking equipment their
plants
their techniques and the
anglers brought their ovens and their
what-have-yous and so did the asians
so that taught me that the general idea
we have that
um foods sort of are rooted in place
in the terroir if you want to use that
fancy term
and it is a mistake that foods
are mobile and when people move food
moves
the other thing i learned was
that when you
have a political change of the chain
kind you had in hawaii
you have going along with it almost
invariably a culinary change
that if you have a new identity
as the state as citizens of the state of
hawaii
you have to have a state food and you
have
to distinguish that from other states
um and so what happened in hawaii
was that these three groups
yes semi-deliberately deliberately
created what in hawaii
is called local food but it's local
not because of the terroir but
uh because of the cultures well that's
exactly what i was uh
inspired to ask by what you just said i
mean this idea
of course that when people move in
either colonizing or
immigrating they bring food along with
them but i'm wondering
is it mostly just because that's what
they like to eat and therefore they
bring it in
or is it more deliberate as in this is
our
culture we need to preserve it or even
impose it on where we're going
i think it's the the latter um
most people it's not a fashionable thing
to say nowadays
it was once throughout history that you
are
what you eat um and
people still to a very large extent
um deep down tend
to believe that and it's
uh yes so when people
move and i i notice it myself i've moved
around the world a fair bit
um from england to america to hawaii to
mexico with lots of stays in other
places and people say
ah but you know when you lived in mexico
didn't you just
eat mexican all the time no no no
because
um that's too abrupt to change i love
mexican food but i'm not going to just
suddenly abandon the accumulated
experience of many years
to go um completely
uh to completely change my lifestyle
yeah maybe if it's not quite we are what
we eat but but certainly
what we choose to eat is a very
important part of who we choose to be
right i mean uh we i always joke when
when we've had thai foods last night and
it's like well we can't have thai food
tonight but
of course thai people have it every
night right but there's something
different in our expectations that goes
into who we are
so let's go all the way back i mean
cooking
by itself is a pretty artificial seeming
thing i know there's like
isolated stories of different animal
species that
that cook in some very very broad sense
but when did cooking start among human
beings is this something that historians
know anything about
um that's really in anthropological
territory
and there's a huge amount of work going
on about that at the moment
um i think one of the things that
anthropologists are gradually realizing
is that cooking is not just a matter of
heat
first of all they thought you know once
you've got the mastery of
fire then you've got cooking
but cooking um
i keep looking for a good word
processing preparing
has at least five different
very different kind of processes going
on there are the thermal changes that
you get
by the use of fire or ice there are the
mechanical changes by grinding or
chopping
there are the chemical changes by
soaking
in alkali or acid there are the
microbiological changes
associated with fermentation and the
biological changes because although we
don't do it now
in the ancient world people also saw
breeding plants
as a part of cooking because as you
probably know
most of the plants that we eat today
have been dramatically modified by human
beings
so that this whole business of
plants and animals are just the raw
materials of food they're not
food um although people
talk about farmers as producing food all
the time they don't they produce the raw
materials
and it's what happens afterwards these
five well
the breeding of plants doesn't happen
afterwards but the other four
happen afterwards and usually
not just one of them i mean you normally
chop and
heat or ferment and um
heat or use chemicals and
so that uh from very
i mean this makes it terribly difficult
to give a date
it's a process that goes along with
becoming human
as this amazing set of technologies are
gradually mastered
and presumably it goes along with again
this
i know nothing about this except from
skimming your book so it's
oversimplified in my head but there was
a transition
from being a hunter-gatherer kind of
society to being agricultural kind of
society did
did we have what we would today
recognize as cooking
even back in the hunter-gatherer days oh
absolutely
oh absolutely and in fact i really would
like to
argue against that uh
periodization as historians call it that
is so deeply
embedded in our culture that it's
hunter-gatherer and then an agricultural
revolution i figured you probably would
but i
had to set the stage so no i mean i
think that
the i mean what agriculture is basically
about
is either grains in the temperate
world or sometimes in the tropical world
with rice
or roots taro
cassava potatoes what have you
particularly the grains they are
incredibly difficult
to prepare cook you are not going to
farm grains
until you have learnt to cook grains
so the important transition is
a transition from a very very mixed diet
to the mastery of grains being able to
take these
teeny hard well protected by nasty tough
husks
little things and turn them into
something that humans can actually eat
that was an impressive part of your book
where you discuss
the grains because they're so important
everywhere in what we eat
that you really made the case it's hard
to eat grains
were you telling the story about your
father who tried he was a farmer and uh
he kind of failed to make grain his own
grains into food
yes yes i mean you know he thought he
could just
grind them and they had already been
uh thrashed in the combine harvester so
he didn't have to get the outer parts
off
all he had to do was to grind them
and in those days there were not handy
little youtubes
that you could see about how to grind
the grain so
so he was just telling me he tried with
a pestle and water you cannot smash
grains into
flour and so but they are both
ubiquitous
and and fairly early in the development
of cuisine so
what was it that inspired people to work
so hard to figure out how to make grains
edible
i think i mean the inventorying
of uh the earth's resources that early
humans did was unbelievably impressive i
mean they must have tried
everything and the nice thing about
i mean what they i don't know whether
they realize this consciously
but the parts of plants that actually
have lots of nutrients because they
support the new plants
are either the grains or the roots
and so that means that they are full of
nutrients
it means um that they
are um not only
let's just stick to the grains because
the roots are not so important they tend
to be toxic
but the the
grains can they have many advantages
they have a very high nutrient to weight
value
so that you can move them a reasonable
distance like 10 miles without a horse
um or an ox or water
they are storable because they are
designed
by nature to be stored they can support
towns because of these two features but
the one
that i think is really important and
that
um the people who the archaeologists and
historians who've looked at grains
haven't mentioned is
they can be turned into almost anything
i mean we think of brains as making
bread or
rice or tortillas
but you know they also contain um
the carbohydrates can be turned into
sugars and the chinese learn to do that
very early we still do it with
corn syrup uh they can be turned into
fats um they can be turned into
condiments
as the chinese do with their various
um fermented pastes and soy sauces and
things
so you know i mean if you've got grains
you can practically
produce the whole of the human diet and
of course they've been turned into meat
i mean because if animals eat them but
and booms don't forget booze right oh oh
well i shouldn't forget blue sugar
that's very important
no i mean no definitely not so so i mean
they're that that just
it that they're just amazing um it's not
easy to do this but it is in you know
you have got something that you can
really
depend on and and dependability also
right i mean it's sort of reliable in
the sense you don't have to go out and
hunt for it or or even wait for it you
can store it over the season right you
can eat it and winter
if you grew it inside provided the
locusts don't come and
hailstone doesn't come and what have you
yep
we all know that it can be difficult to
start an exercise program
but the feeling you get once you've
started is a real thrill
and with peloton it's especially easy to
have that feeling available
in the convenience of your own home i
can tell you from experience that once
you get on the bike and start going
the initial reluctance goes away and
it's very exciting it's very thrilling
to follow along with a motivated
instructor
amazing music and endless fitness
variety with epic artist collaborations
and instructor curated playlists
peloton's music experience is unlike any
other
whether you're in the mood for some
hip-hop pop or country
the peloton bike has the right music to
keep you entertained and motivated all
year long
and there are classes for every level
from beginner programs to tabata
intervals
peloton meets you at every step in your
fitness journey and with an endless
variety of live
and on-demand cycling classes plus live
and on-demand
strength yoga and stretching classes off
the bike you'll keep coming back for
more so get started on your peloton
journey by going to one
peloton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o
and you mentioned the word towns so
already we see a connection between
you know the human way of life and the
food that they're eating when you have a
town and maybe you have some
differentiation
in uh occupations like not everyone is
doing the same thing
there can be farmers and grains are a
good target for them
yes i mean you don't find
cities in societies that don't eat
grains
um obviously the eating of grains comes
way before
cities it comes way before agriculture
but uh it does allow that
interesting so yeah so i wonder how much
i don't know how cities developed either
but i wonder how much
was uh freedom from
spending time hunting etc once you could
farm your greens
yes and also um freedom
to um uh
settle in larger groups because you can
bring them in
no i mean what human cooking does and i
this begins i think before the grains
even with hunter-gatherers
but it continues with the grains i mean
this whole business of cooking
broadly understood um externalizes
what animals have to do for themselves
animals have to chew
which we don't even think about but it
is a very time
consuming business for a chimp to chew a
monkey
takes about five hours so um
you know we don't spend five hours a day
chewing and we don't
count the energy and digesting is also a
very
um slow and energy consuming process for
the animals well we
we we do that in the kitchen
um and that frees up lots of human
energy to do
other things the downside of it
is that some proportion
of the human um of humanity has to do
the cooking
and no and i mean that's that's a very
huge burden i mean people talk all the
time if you read history books they say
oh you know agriculture came along and
then you know everybody had to labor in
the
fields and it was such hard work i mean
laboring in the fields
yes it's hard work my father was a
farmer i don't deny that
but one reason perhaps i wrote the book
was
in honor of my mother who did the
cooking and nobody paid any attention to
that but
that was an enormously even in
industrialized
england an enormously time-consuming
business
if you had seven people to feed and
you grew all your own vegetables and
you know so on and so forth it was very
that was a great point in the book
because it reminded me of the ideas of
extended cognition i don't know how much
you follow
people in the study of the mind uh
claiming that what we should count as
our mind is not just our brain but also
like the pieces of paper we write on
and the way that we keep records and our
bodies and so forth are
doing cognitive tasks spiders uh
encode knowledge in their spider web
patterns and so
this is extended metabolism right like
the idea of cooking and so forth uh
off sources some digestive purposes to
things that we can do with our hands
right right no i hadn't heard about
extended cognition but i
i like that idea and i like the idea of
calling it extended metabolism yeah and
so you have a wonderful you know in the
chapters of your book you talk about
the development of cuisines and the
major cuisines uh
throughout history so maybe we can go
through some of those uh
was the what you call the sacrificial
cuisine of barley and wheat was that the
first major cuisine worldwide or
or is it do we not even know enough to
say something like that well
let me just say a word about cuisine
because
in english it tends to suggest something
very snobby
unfortunately we don't have a word
in english for a
style of cooking and eating
in um spanish for example
um la cocina means both the kitchen
and the style of cooking you don't so
i use the word cuisine not not to talk
about something fancy but to talk about
a particular style of cooking
and going back to cognition i think what
tends to hold cuisines together
is our ideas the the
what we're doing with the cuisine so
now we get to sacrificial cuisines
finally
um in the ancient
world there are many sacrificial
cuisines but what they have in common
is a belief that the gods
provided us with food
and that in return that particularly the
grains and
all the early gods in china or
greece or what have you tend to be grain
gods
and in other parts of the world there
are you know demeter and
uh what's a chinese one i'm blocking on
it but never mind
um the millet guard in china um
and that in return um in order to
uh ensure a supply
of the basics of food humans have
to feed the gods which they do by
sacrificing to the gods and the aromas
when the
sacrificed goods are cooked the aromas
rise to the gods
and feed them and it's a very um
kind of practical view of you know
how you try to live in a difficult and
dangerous world with those
locusts and hailstorms that might
destroy your food that you have to
undertake this bargaining position
to whatever those powers up there are
i'm going to admit that i'm forgetting
the details of the story but
way back in cain and abel in genesis
didn't one of them
sacrifice a lamb and the other some
plants and and god judged them harshly i
forget which one was
was judged what it was i don't remember
no i mean
whether it's the bible whether it's the
early
um literature in china whether
it's greece uh persia this
these kinds of stories about offering
the gods
your most precious things which are
always meat
and grains basically um
in return for the gods hopefully
[Music]
taking care of you yes i mean that's
very interesting because i
wouldn't have guessed that i mean if you
if you say after the fact that there's a
particular religion that that
in which sacrificing to the gods plays a
big role i'm saying okay i get that
but the fact that it's universal over
very different disconnected cultures
is kind of amazing it was something
where very different people said yeah
this is the way to go
yeah i mean there are the first when i'm
looking at the very earl these early
formal cuisines
in the very first empires which is when
we first got
much written evidence about what's going
on
it's very striking that around the globe
not only are they sacrificial cuisines
but they all believe
in that different levels of
life have different kinds of food
appropriate to them even different
classes of human beings and
that the cooking is part of a whole
cosmic process where the power of
the heat of the sun and the rays of the
moon drive
the processes on the earth
and though at a very general level those
three
principles seem to be very very
widespread
now is this just a response
you know that a human cognition
human brains have to the world they're
trying to
live in and make sense of or is there a
whole bunch of contact
that uh you know everybody did
apparently you know come out of africa
at least that's the standard story right
now
and you know what point we don't know
right but okay but despite the fact that
maybe everyone did it you do
sort of um put your finger on this
particular
set of cultures in the middle east uh
which you associate with the barley and
wheat
kinds of cuisines so what were those
folks eating and how did they think
about eating back in those days
okay well um
plato and aristotle would have eaten um
barley bannocks that is they that stage
wheat was still
not the predominant grain it was the
secondary one
so they would have ground up barley
and eaten it as basically flatbreads
on an open fire um they
would have eaten essentially a
vegetarian diet
most of the year um
and meat was um
normally eaten only in association with
the sacrifice
so that the big event at the olympics if
you like a nice story
is not well it is the races but it is
also
the final uh ceremony which
is when 30 oxen are brought
in and slaughtered
and i so think of the night the sort of
practicalities of this
takes a certain amount of time to get an
animal in and slaughter it and cut it
up and then put it on the sacrificial
fire and then everybody feasts on
on on what turns out if you do the
arithmetic to be a rather small piece of
meat
so the concessions at the stadium uh are
as early as the sports
themselves in other words
i know that even today the only reason
i'll go to a baseball game is to just
have a hot dog and sit outside on a nice
day
so some things never change um but you
then
contrast this with what you identify as
a buddhist
kind of cuisine uh based mostly on rice
and is that
how does that fit in with the idea that
i would have that uh
all of east asia eats rice all the time
did buddhism really
has some responsibility for bringing
rice to china and japan and korea
oh yes um millet was the original grain
uh i mean you know millet that little
thing
that you know goes in bird seed feeders
i've heard of it
it's not actually a thing it's a lot of
different
species that have very tiny grains and
that's what confucius would have eaten
um or steamed millet
um and i mean it's not that boudin
though there was rice in various parts
of
south china very early on
but
[Music]
when you get
a state
beginning to take these new kinds of
religions that begin
say 500 bc uh buddhism and then
christianity and
manichaeism and later islam
when then um this
political religious um
coalition um tends to have
preferred foods and preferred festivals
most of them are set
up in opposition to these earlier
sacrificial cuisines
i mean they're turning away from the
sacrifice
and in instituting a new
kind of ethics and
[Applause]
understanding of the world where no
longer do you have to
placate the gods you have a different
relation to them
and in buddhism um
the buddha um the the stories say that
he uh turned away from the killing of
animals that's away from the sacrifice
and so in buddhism there's an avoidance
of meat it's not complete but it's there
and so the cherished foods instead of
being meat become
sugar and butter and
rice and in india before buddhism came
along
i'm guessing it was mostly hindu or
pre-hindu and
were they not eating rice are they
eating something different
were they not eating rice yeah um
they were eating rice and millet i mean
still the poor in india today
this thing called millet that nobody in
america thinks of as human food
um that was incredibly important it is a
grain
and you know that's what most people did
and
many still do eat in india so this
i mean rice has always been particularly
white rice it's a very elite food
and so when we're talking about buddhist
changing things
we are talking um primarily about
the ruling classes okay and did that
tell me more about the that transition
in china because i don't know
that much about it i mean confucianism
is early
and was sort of the established way of
thinking about things
buddhism never became the dominant uh
religion in china as far as i understand
although it did get quite a foothold it
became pretty much the dominant religion
between about
um now please if you've got listeners
who are experts on buddhism in china
that i probably
i would need to look in the book and get
the exact centuries but i think between
the third and the eighth
century okay um buddhism becomes very
dominant
in china and then there's a reaction
back
against it and um taoism and
um confucianism there's always been a
complicated dance between those three in
china
but the buddhists in some sense won the
culinary battle they brought their rice
in and that uh
that stuck with us they made a huge
difference to chinese cuisine yes i mean
it's an interesting story because you
say well how did they
do it you've got you know central asia
there in the middle
and the answer is well of course central
asia was a major
uh root but also
that you don't need vast numbers of
people if you can change minds
and what happened was that
certain indian rulers sent people
sent envoys to china
to india to learn this new religion and
they came back
and they brought the texts and they
brought the ideas and they brought
you know the way of eating and
so uh it's
yet i mean for a period and it was a
very
very big thing because you know for the
chinese
red is the color of happiness it's a
very
good color and in buddhism red
stands for meat and alcohol and things
you don't want
and and white is the very good color so
you know they're all these all these
things
have to be negotiated it takes a long
time
but yes buddhism dramatically changes
the food of first china and then japan
and korea
and it's interesting because we
previously hinted at and i'm sure we'll
get to
uh the colonialism aspect and the empire
aspect but
this is not that really i mean it's
almost like a
cultural religious exchange that kind of
uh
sweeps the country in the in the case of
of china did it happen at the
common level first or the elite level
first and then trickle down do we know
things like that
i i would say at the elite
level i mean just simply the logistics
of learning about buddhism from
thousands of miles away and getting the
texts
you know that's not something that
common people can do
so this yes i think this is a kind of
cultural
colonialism sometimes you know obviously
and i don't want to jump ahead as you
very meticulously go through my book
i mean that that it's not
always gentle either either the persian
empire
earlier in the mediterranean was not a
gentle empire
and when the mongols come into china
that's not a gentle
empire a gentle colonization either
so it comes in different forms there's
nothing better than the feeling of
learning
something new and there's no more fun
and easy way to do that than with the
great courses plus
the great courses plus is a streaming
service with thousands of hours of
fascinating content across hundreds of
topics
and right now there's an incredible deal
for mindscape listeners you get a free
trial
and 20 off when you sign up for an
annual membership
at the special url the great courses
plus
slash mindscape that's a world of
knowledge for less than what most of us
pay on coffee each month
i've done courses with the great courses
like my course on the higgs boson and
beyond
i remember the excitement that we had
discovering the higgs boson
we might be close to that again with new
anomalies in particle physics so this
would be a great time to learn about the
standard model and the experiments
behind it
so go now to the great courses plus dot
com
slash mindscape to get your free trial
and listeners will get 20
off the annual membership that's the
great courses plus dot com
slash mindscape well let's jump ahead
and he's not that far ahead because the
next uh
great cuisine that you study is is
you've grouped together
islam and the mongols in an interesting
way i mean what what was
uh specific about their cuisine
uh well um i put them together but
because in um although
christianity um which
is now a huge world religion and was
supported by
states comes before islam
chronologically in fact um
it was largely restricted to western
europe
right most of that time whereas
islam and other religions of the middle
east
explode across
central asia and um
down into west africa and east africa
um in the between the seventh and
eleventh or twelfth centuries so in that
sense
they are the next big event in
culinary history um
islam is not a set in in islam
[Music]
here you have another different working
of this grain
uh meat alcohol trio i hadn't mentioned
alcohol so much before but
it's important for islam the preferred
foods in islam
are very much meat and they keep a form
of the sacrifice they don't
entirely get rid of it and they
are very big wheat eaters but
of course they tend to avoid alcohol
um so it that's the kind of
uh set up um and they develop
uh weak cuisines very um
dramatically with
flatbreads and noodles and
dishes like that and these get
transmitted they also do wonderful
things with
sugar which they get from india
and distillation which is not for
alcohol
so much as for essences their their
technology of food is
is really impressive i mean maybe it's
just too obvious even to mention but
uh one of the great things about either
flatbreads made from wheat
or bowls of rice is that they can be the
base
of some food stuff right you can put
other things on them
sauces and spices and meats and
vegetables and
that seems to be a universal phenomenon
am i correcting that
yes i think so i mean yeah everyone came
up with the idea with this
for the sandwich or the taco or whatever
it is
yes yes i mean uh you
you get your grain and for most people
grains would have been 80 or 90 percent
of their
um calorie intake and then you have
something to make the grain go down
which is you know a little bit of sauce
or
something spicy or something um
salty and i'm not sure how this fits
into your classification of cuisines but
in my
very naive picture of it uh in asia
and maybe also in africa the idea of
spices was very very important right and
maybe
less important than it was in western
europe at the time is that a fair
comparison uh western europe love
spices from the middle ages on or even
from the roman period on
i mean the trouble is that most of the
things that we now classify
as spices tend to be tropical so they're
difficult
to you can't grow them in western europe
um they did have i mean people say
it was bland um there is horseradish and
there is mustard
and if you've ever and the mustard is
not like your little
american yellow jar this is
hot more serious yes horseradish so
yeah i think something
you know some condiment that has a
strong
either pecan or salty taste
or sweet taste but that's more difficult
um
is pretty much universal okay good that
that does make sense but uh okay and
then the final uh
pre-modern if you want cuisine that you
focus on is
christian i suppose european right uh
and and so what made that different from
the islamic and the buddhist
ways of eating well again they have a
different
set of preferred foods i mean wine is
very important and grapes are very
important
they use raised bread not flat bread
lamb is important also be
it's a meat cuisine um lots
of fasting in most christian
[Music]
pre-protestant
cuisines fasting almost uh 50 percent of
the year
for most places um
and something that is shared in common
with the
religions in other parts of the world
is that it is the religious
houses and the religious establishment
that is responsible for feeding those
who
are in in great poverty
um that that is fairly universal it's
not the state's business it's the
although the state sponsors the the
religion
um up until you know the
modern period um the the
the religious houses um have the
responsibility for feeding the poor
so is that a european christian thing or
is that more universal
that's universal okay and uh you
mentioned the fasting so what would it
what would
fasting have meant to europeans in the
middle ages and it's not like you know
people today take two weeks of two days
of the week maybe and
eat fewer calories to lose weight oh no
it's not
it's no meat no animal products um
so um like
very much like the greek orthodox church
today
um this goes on for 40 days in length in
the spring
prior to easter and for a number of
weeks before
christmas and for many day in every
friday
um so you are eating a vegetarian or a
vegan cuisine um for fifty percent of
the year
okay and then uh of course europe
explodes across
the world right i mean they start being
and europe explodes across the world
and um particularly to the americas
early i mean and the spanish are really
the spanish and the portuguese are the
really
important ones in spreading this kind of
christian cuisine
around the world and presumably it i
mean more than presumably it certainly
goes both ways in terms of
flavors and ingredients being brought
back from one's colonies
to the homeland but at the same time
you're saying the sort of style of
eating was brought
from the imperial power to the colonies
uh
let's look at two of the spanish ones
mexico and the philippines
good okay when the spanish went
to mexico they just took their entire
kitchen
okay i mean they did not eat tortillas
if they could avoid it
i mean the first few years they had to
eat tortillas but they
they just they move their cuisine
they're not going to eat
chilies and and tortillas
uh when they get to the philippines um
pretty much the same kind of thing
they can't do it quite so far this is
the
forcefully there because getting across
the pacific is very
difficult but you know the they do try
to set up
a spanish cuisine in the philippines
what do they bring back there is not oh
let me get on a high horse
please um there is not a colombian
exchange
in cuisine there is a colombian exchange
with plants
colombian exchanges this sprays that i
think
uh alfred crosby the historian set up
to talk about how uh
when uh europeans reach the americas
there was an exchange of
plants and animals and diseases across
the atlantic
doesn't happen with food we still
anglos still have not learned the basic
techniques
of mexican cooking we can't
make we don't make corn tortillas by
using alkali
we do not basically use dehydrated
and rehydrated chiles to
create the basis of our sources
we don't use them for color and
flavor and texture we use them for heat
and that is also true of say um uh
europe uh eurasia when
maize goes to africa
and uh europe the techniques for
processing it don't go
it's only the plant same thing with
chilies the techniques don't go
just the plant interesting so that
is i think again because of the power
relations
right they people don't you know
we've conquered the americas we don't
want to eat like them
yes if we can take these plants and make
use of them we will do
now in the case of west africa and maze
i mean it's partly that they
they that the techniques are just not
transmitted because there's not much
back movement into west africa but
in europe people don't know how to
process
didn't know how to process maze the the
american way
that's right it's very interesting yeah
the idea that it was not quite an
exchange of equal partners but we
but we did bring ingredients back they
did bring ingredients back to europe
that were
ultimately very influential uh you you
talk a lot about potatoes or at least
the potato made a big influence on me
the whole
fact that potatoes are not easy to grow
and they needed to figure out
uh what to do with them when they
brought them back to europe
yes and people really didn't like them
i mean it's it takes 200 years 300 years
for the potato
to make it really into european cuisine
it's in the late 18th and
early 19th century when the european
population is beginning to explode
and rulers are desperate desperate
because
starvation is lurking everywhere famine
and they are forcing people to eat
potatoes
they were not welcomed and really they
have only been welcomed once they get a
lot of fat in them
well was it more that we cultivated the
actual potato or is that we just learned
to
douse them in butter or fat or sour
cream um
first of all potato had to be changed
to um a different
day they come from the southern
hemisphere and
growing them in the northern hemisphere
where is not easy
right so a lot of breeding had to go on
um but also you know if you're eating 90
white bread if nine if white not
actually they weren't most people were
eating poorer bread
brown bread yeah wholemeal breads but if
if bread
is you know give us this day our daily
bread
is the prayer this is this is
food and then you give somebody a boiled
potato
which doesn't have any consistency and
not much taste
well these many of them didn't have much
taste
that's not food and you make the point
that french fries
were uh elite for a long time because uh
they were hard to make it was until the
frozen french fry came on the scene the
60s and 70s that they became
food of the people well french fries yes
they were elite they were invented
sometime during the 19th century and
you know they're very difficult to make
you have to have a big pot of
fat which is very expensive way out of
the resources of most people and then
you have to fry
the potatoes once take them outside
drain them heat the oil to a slightly
higher temperature
fry them again and then serve them
so this is taking a poor ingredient
and by massive processing turn it
into something that is an elite food
and as it was until you say the 70s and
80s when
the mccain industry gets going with
frozen french fries where most of the
preparation has been done for you
and this is it's a characteristic of
something you've already mentioned but
maybe it's worth
driving home the idea that all the
ingredients of the food we eat now
whether it's the
vegetables or the grains or even the
meats uh
would have been unrecognizable several
centuries ago we've done
so much cultivation and breeding that
tomatoes carrots beef whatever chicken
is just a very different thing than it
was
back in the day the prevalent
nostalgia about the better food of the
past
that i rage about all the time
this is part of it most of our foods now
are much better and you you mentioned
this in the case of spain but this idea
of the connection of cuisine and
national
character or national pride uh is is
worth going into
in this colonial era in particular i
mean there was french food there was
british food they were they were
different
and and there was this feeling that
we're bringing civilization
as well as cuisine to the world yes
i'm not sure how
much they were actually national
as uh until
the end of the 18th or the 19th century
i think french and
well there's a complicated thing in
there
high-end i mean the french didn't eat
what we think of as french food
until about the 1930s the italians
didn't eat what we think of as italian
food until the 1950s
most most of the national cuisines that
we now
see are very recent you know nations are
pretty recent
inventions most nations were not really
um around in anything like
our sense of the world nate word nation
until um a hundred a couple of hundred
years ago
and the vast majority of them in the
last 50 years
so that uh until
nations sort of really get established
which is in the 20th century
class is much more important in food
than a nation so
just to illustrate that people often ask
me about you know oh well
why did the french have such great food
and the english have such terrible food
and that's to misinterpret it because
the
elite in the 19th century ate french
food
in england in france in america
in chile in japan in india everywhere
that was the food of the international
elite
and in so far as there were national
cuisines they were among the middle or
working classes
is there a simple answer probably not
very simple but how did that happen how
did
french high cuisine or cuisine uh become
the international food of diplomacy in
the elites worldwide
um i
why french as opposed to english
i think the english sort of seeded that
french
you know we've got the bigger empire you
could do the diplomacy
i don't know um
but certainly the i mean in
it the kind of thing that julia child
was teaching at least until she kind of
toned down
the stuff was not what
ordinary french people ate it was what
uh very well to do french people ate
and the french had this massive
export industry of sending chefs
and butchers and bakers and everything
around the world to prepare this for
the courts and the ambassadors and
you know the newly rich in the
industrializing nations
i mean i'm getting a bit of a theme
maybe i'm overreaching here so you can
correct me
but uh there's you know an ongoing set
of debates within history
about how much things are geographically
determined right you know local weather
conditions and soil conditions and
things like that but
you're giving a lot of credit to ideas
in the broadest sense right
the idea that people just like their
food and they're going to spread it and
evangelize for it and it works in some
sense
um yes i mean i
do want maybe i'm overreacting
to the story that about
the origin and that
i'm now just going to talk about food
not about
geographic determinism generally um i
think this idea that our food
is somehow rooted in the land um
comes along in the 1930s
and i think it's the french who
invented and i think they have a real
problem from say the end of the 19th
century through the beginning of world
war ii
um they both got um they have a republic
they have to try to say that every
they have to try to create a french
cuisine that french people actually eat
as opposed to one that is just for the
courts
they are in trouble with the wine
industry
and um so they developed this
idea of terroir and the
regional foods of france coming together
to form a national cuisine
i don't think so but so
yes i want to s
go back to the idea that
our ideas really do shape
what we eat i mean obviously there's
some kind of
if you're in iceland you're not going to
be able to
grow rice and you've got to import it i
mean there is a limit on
what raw materials you can have and how
far you can move them and how much
you're prepared to pay for that
but the way you think about eating
um the way you link it to your
other beliefs about politics or religion
or whatever it happens to be
i think those are more important
than and the idea in uh britain as
opposed to france
was beef and bread i think as you as you
make the point and and that carried over
here into the united states and we're
remarkably
beef and bread-based culture to this day
yes and i think
i mean the what i think the great
contribution of britain to food was and
it's a mixed contribution but was to say
that as and it was very slow and halting
as we
extend the franchise as we move towards
a democracy
and this is really important in america
um when america declares itself a
republic instead of a a monarchy
um if we're going to do this everybody
who is
a citizen has to be able to eat
the same thing and that's a powerful
idea i mean
it's an amazing idea and i think you see
it all the time in american elections
because
american presidents you know they have
to go
and eat a hamburger somewhere every
i mean and and you know
queen elizabeth is not going to go and
stand somewhere and eat a hamburger that
so when people will sort of laugh at
you know mcdonald's or something it's
actually
in some ways a very touching and amazing
thing
that an entire nation
can in fact eat something like that i
mean we're we're now so rich it looks
silly but it's not it's really amazing
you make a lot of the idea that how the
family has eaten
has changed in the last 100 and 200
years
i mean uh what would it have been like
to have your sort of daily
meal in you know 200 years ago in the
u.s oh it'd have been rough
you wouldn't have had you'd all of them
if you were an ordinary person you'd
have had a common bowl
and you'd have had spoons and you've
would have been eating some kind of mush
out of the common bowl all the scraps go
in
yes and it would have been but
i mean and i have very mixed views about
this but the republican and i don't mean
capital r no i mean small uh
tradition in 19th century america um
stressed enormously the idea that
the family unit was sort of the basis
of the republic and that
work was divided between the mother and
the father
provided the income the mother provided
the food on the table
and the table was the place where
children got
both uh moral education in what it was
to be a citizen
and physical nutrition
in terms of making them strong
citizen and
this was again a very powerful idea
um i think in it had many good
aspects i mean it also has the terrible
aspect that the woman is so
tight kitchen so
if we want to do anything like it today
we have to find some way of
changing that part of it
but it was
part of creating an
american um republican slash democratic
slash
liberal slash progressive i know those
are all
have differences but all of them
are anti-counter to our
the aristocratic traditions that had
reigned in the rest of the world
but the idea that you could sit down at
the family meal and have you know
um some vegetables and some meat and
some rolls of bread or whatever
so that was not here 150 years ago
how much is it a technological change
that we're able to store food and and
transport it and freeze it much easier
it's i i mean you
you couldn't have done this without the
industrialization of food
and it's why i am so pro the
industrialization of food
i mean if we went back if we took uh
if everyone knows the name alice waters
i'm sure they do
alice waters uh kind of prescription
of you know home-cooked home-grown food
um it's it it's too labor-intensive it's
too difficult to do
so it it becomes a little bit elitist to
imagine that
we're going to locally pick all of our
stuff and you know
carefully construct it but it's just not
practical over a huge scale is what
you're saying
i don't think so i think you've got to
bring you know
as i said my mother lived in
industrialized britain
and we could buy our bread from a bakery
it was very good bread actually
but you know we did still grow all our
own vegetables
and um milk
and all and if you have to go
if you want to have green beans in july
and cabbage in march unfortunately
because it's the only thing
you have you know you've got to plan
that and you've got seven people
it's it was a full-time job i mean it
wasn't completely full-time she also did
the law
you know other things but um she
couldn't have done that
and held down a regular job and
if you see women being able to
have a an equal part in the workplace
um then you
they have you've got to have the
industrialization of food
if you've got if you want to include the
entire
nation rich poor and rich
eating hamburgers you've got to have
industrialized food
so i mean we could draw a distinction
between fast food all the mcdonald's and
convenient food all uh you know the
frozen food aisle
in our supermarket but uh but
you're making the case for both of these
being a
democratizing influence and even you
know a sort of liberating influence on
half of the population that that
they don't need to spend all their time
cooking food
yeah and i mean i don't think
i mean you know we've got some really
bad
stuff you know cheese curls and i mean
doritos are supposed to be delicious i
think they're disgusting
um but you know we've got
look at our supermarkets i mean you know
you've got 20 different vegetables in
the middle of winter
you've got meat that you know almost
everybody can afford you've got
lentils and brown rice if you want
lentils and brown rice
i mean the american supermarket is
just um
an extraordinary um
phenomenon and so i i mean i would like
to work
always to make things better i i for
example i
i would love to get better institutional
food in hospitals and prisons and
schools and things
um and there's no reason why it can't be
good
um so there's lots of things that are
still wrong but
is there a sense in which uh american
cuisine is
becoming less focused on the traditional
british
uh beef and bread uh strategy that we
are
absorbing influences from outside more
or is that just because
i'm an upper middle class person living
in los angeles and so i have a
completely disordered view of what the
world is like i think
um oh absolutely it's absorbing
i mean you can see it happening day by
day and again it's linked to the
politics
i mean when you get um
all what were called ethnic minorities
demanding that they have a greater place
in society
this is how you can see it happening in
cookbooks in cooking shows
and everything it's not and we're
introdu
it's interesting because it it's it
it can't be absolutely everything so one
of the things i'm trying to watch is
how new rules and new preferences
are being formed out of this potentially
huge amount of stuff we can choose from
and they do have to do with convenience
right and with being ex
everything being extremely tasty
and um with
um individual choice pushed
to i think an almost uh
to an extreme that i'm not sure is
healthy why would it not be healthy say
more about that
uh i don't mean not healthy in the sense
of individual health
i mean not healthy for a society
um because um eating together
eating somebody else's food
says because we are what we eat if i eat
your food i am acknowledging that you
are somebody i would like to be
like or i can accept
right i mean and going back to hawaii
where i started
i mean it was absolutely essential to
the creation of
a civil uh society in the new state of
hawaii
that you and ate other people's food
right and now if you try to have a party
you know one person doesn't is a
pescetarian and one is a
vegan and one i see um
i think it's important for children to
learn to eat things they don't
like sometimes i'm on your side there
i'm reminded of a
remark made by roy choi who is a local
well-known chef
he started the koji barbecue truck uh
and he he explained that uh his goal was
to sell
korean food in places in los angeles
where people didn't eat that much korean
food and so
he just decided it wasn't for culinary
reasons but he decided to
serve it in the form of tacos because
that's what americans would eat
and you know the implicit message being
that tacos are american
right even though of course we borrowed
even those but they were a
delivery mechanism for this more exotic
korean food and that worked very very
well
but we definitely seem to be learning to
appreciate
uh more asian food and i i guess what
i'm getting at is i both feel what you
just said
about the hyper individualization making
it more difficult to have communal
meals but also uh and opening up to
things beyond hamburgers and and chicken
and things like that which
which i would take to be a good sign oh
yes absolutely
yeah and you know it's very exciting and
which bits because we can't accept
all korean food and all vietnamese food
and
all english food and all because i took
too much of it
yeah so which
which bits and you can see certain bits
coming out
you know i mean of the different
traditions
and do you think i don't know if that's
if how much credit is due to
um alice waters and chapanese and stuff
like that but we now have a whole
celebrity chef culture right we have the
food network we have these attempts to
make very
fancy food do you think that's a passing
fad do you think that's you know part of
post-modernity or
are we is this a is this something that
we should look forward to
it's i mean personally i i
i find it rather boring i did once
go to one of the top 10 restaurants in
the world and i had a lovely time
and it something i think it's nice if
everyone can do once in a lifetime
but i have to sit there for three hours
on a regular basis
admiring what the chef has produced
no thank you
i think we are going well i'd like
to see because this has been a lot
about reinventing the cook as artists
to give them extra status um
and maybe they've achieved that status
now
and you're seeing some of them say well
you know we've now got to do
sort of socially um important things
like jose andres who's been feeding
people in epidemics
um it seems i mean we can't
have a society full of little individual
restaurants
run by um budding artists i don't think
we can support
that number but if they can turn some of
that energy
into making you know it
taking the burden off the housewife
making better industrial food or take
out food
or not industry institutional or take
out or fast food um
that would be an incredible gift to
society
well maybe just to wrap things up then
uh
let's look into the future a little bit
um you know this has been a long story
of
the interrelationship between food
technology and food politics and food
culture
these are all continuing to change
especially on the technology side right
we have artificial meats
synthetic biology is letting us do new
things do you think that
science and technology as well as
politics are going to be dramatically
changing how we eat in the years to come
i'm always a bit nervous about
projections um
i don't it depends on your time scale
um people i mean i
am old enough now to have seen a
dramatic change in my lifetime
but it's not overnight um it's very hard
to
change food habits overnight and it's
probably not a good thing either
physiologically or psychologically
so i think i i would see an evolution
um and say within a generation or two
generations
um a very large change but it's not
you know if artificial meats come on the
market uh
well they are on the market um you know
it's not going to mean that
two years down the road uh traditional
meat
has vanished i sure don't think yeah
but maybe um hand in hand with that
do people spend less time sitting down
at family meals these days than they did
50 years ago
i suspect so data on this
is really hard to get um
and i mean i'm not committed
as the 19th century american republicans
were
to kind of um
social um interaction
being primarily at
the right the meal or and particularly
at the family meal i mean there are
other
or it doesn't have to be home cooked by
mother
i do think as a society
comparing say living in mexico to living
in the united states
um in a similar kind of socio-economic
environment one of the things we have
lost in the united states
is the ability to socialize well
and enjoy it and take the time to do it
and i regret that and i think
it would be great if we could move to a
sort of
not a slightly more relaxed attitude to
spending time
with other people whom we like or find
interesting um so
yeah i think there's room there uh i
don't know what your opinion is but i
would love to see
more um more
more care and more attention given to
how we interact no i i i actually yeah i
mean i can't agree more
the uh one thing that is clear is that
we work too much
and we're too busy and now that we have
the convenience of all this food that we
can get
any ingredient at any time of the year
we want we should take advantage of that
and sit down and enjoy it with each
other a little bit more often
all right that's a great place to end
rachel louden thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast
oh thank you for having me
[Music]
you